[Music]
unfortunately I'm rather pessimistic
about the way we teach science and some
people asks me a simple question their
visitors from overseas and they say that
Wow America has so many Nobel laureates
but it has one of the worst educational
programs known to science this is
measurable our kids score dead last of
all all the other developed nations and
our students actually rank a little bit
below the students of Jordan in science
and math tests so my friends from
overseas asked a simple question why
doesn't America collapse I mean where do
all these Nobel laureates come from and
these innovations that we see coming
from Silicon Valley well America has
several secret weapons that most nations
have never heard of first of all our
secret weapon the weapon that keeps us
at the forefront of innovation and
scientific progress in high-tech is the
h-1b that is our secret weapon that most
nations and people have never heard of
the h-1b is the genius visa you are
quote a genius PhD you have wealth
you're an established figure zoom you go
right into the United States to energize
Silicon Valley which is 50% foreign-born
yes you see Bill Gates yes you see Steve
Jobs out there but 50% of the Enderson
scientists behind Bill Gates and Steve
Jobs are foreign-born there's a brain
drain a tremendous brain drain into the
United States the top talent comes here
this is where innovation takes place and
is rewarded financially but there are
other reasons why America does catch up
first of all America does quote see the
genius in the classroom the young Bill
Gates the young Steve Jobs the young
Albert Einstein in the East there is
this Confucian tradition that you're not
supposed to make your peers look bad by
excelling and trying to achieve
something beyond their abilities however
in the West we have another saying and
that is the squeaky wheel gets the
grease so
so the innovators the real imaginative
thinkers they are rewarded in the
American system while in the East they
are hammered down and third our college
system is not so bad
even though while high school system
graduates generations of near illiterate
students by the time they get hit
college then that's when they begin to
accelerate that's when they begin to get
up to speed but you know we cannot
sustain our scientific establishment
this way we cannot continue to pend on
foreign scientists we cannot continue to
depend on the the genius that may or may
not arise and we certainly can't depend
upon college being a remedial high
school